I like it
Why me?
Naka City You gave me a name, so
I had a hard time.
You know,
[music
] I think it's because of
that, but since that day, I've
only seen strawberries -- You
changed this a while ago,
right
?  I got a new one It's
disgusting, isn't it?
I
'm just a man and I'm immediately jealous of someone who has the right to stand next to strawberries I
'm dying to struggle with 7 people It's
selfish, isn't
it
annoying?  Me and
me
It's
okay if it's troublesome If you're going to say it works, it's me too It's
troublesome for us But
recently I've started to think that it's
okay Maybe the accumulation of this kind of thing is alive  I'm
sure I can't give up right away I can't give up I know I
'm happy